This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Audible
The CDC was just caught using expired disinfectant
in their labs, which got me thinking…
Disinfectant expires?!
WHAT?!
Howdy gang, Trace here with some DNews for
ya!
The CDC's use of expired cleanser was discovered
after 75 employees were accidentally exposed
to live anthrax last month, and the USDA stepped
in to look at their procedures to see who
screwed up.
Most labs use bleach as their disinfectant,
because the active ingredient, hypochlorous
acid, [a]causes the proteins in bacteria to
unfold and the bacteria die.
Bleach is what was being used by the CDC in
their labs -- and it has an expiration date
of only six months from date of manufacture,
so probably three to five months once you
get it home.
It expires because the sodium hypochlorite
decomposes over time.
The cooler the storage area the better, but
bleach manufactured and stored in the warm
summer months, WILL degrade faster.
Expiration dates are used by manufacturers
not to tell you, "time to throw this away,"
but more to say, 'we cannot guarantee this
product is perfect anymore.'
The dates are usually printed on the product,
and there are LOTS of them.
The latex in a condom has an expiration date
of five years, because the latex needs to
be moist… moist… moist… to work.
And after five years, the brand can't guarantee
the latex hasn't degraded from drying.
If it has spermicide, it's even shorter, only
three years.
Like with bleach, spermicides' active ingredient
degrades over time.
Sunscreen also expires, mainly because the
tiny particles inside the solution clump together
as the sunscreen ages, this decreases the
effectiveness and causes the sunscreen to
eventually become crappy.
Mascara expires after two or three months,
so if you're going to splurge on that fancy
lash-lengthening formula, use it all.
Why?
Because your eyes are dirty, once it has been
used, the mascara becomes a breeding ground
for bacteria.
After the date, the bacteria could have build
up enough to cause eye infections like conjunctivitis
-- or pinkeye.
And you should DEFINITELY get rid of a loofa
after THREE TO FOUR WEEKS!
Bacteria folks.
It's growing on stuff.
It's all about the active ingredients.
Anti-acne creams usually break down within
three months of first opening, sometimes sooner,
if they're natural.
Hair gel and hairspray lasts two to three
years.
Soap usually expires in 18 months to two years;
especially if it contains essential oils!
Soap is made of lye -- a generic term for
an alkaline solution -- and a collection of
fats.
Over time, the lye gets less potent and the
fats degrade… sensing a pattern here?
Exactly.
It's not just bathroom stuff, motor oil is
organic, it used to be tiny plants and animals
remember?
FOSSIL fuels!
Like all the other things, once it's open
the air begins to break it down and after
90 days it's expired; unopened it can last
as maybe five years.
Alkaline batteries last five years, too.
The chemicals inside batteries will only hold
a charge for so long -- and because their
elements are different, lithium batteries
can as 10 years.
There are a LOT of things with expiration
dates, and while you might not have to pay
attention to them all the time, it's good
to take note.
The CDC bleach, by the way, would still be
okay to use up to nine months after manufacture,
but every month more of the acid is depleted.
Hopefully, the CDC will pony up for some new
cleaner, and so should you.
Kinda makes those trips to Costco seem…
well… silly… don't it?
There are two things that I found that never
expire.
Honey, and nail polish remover.
Yep.
So that's good to know I guess.
What other things have surprising shelf lifes?
Tell us yours below, and if you love exploring
your world as much as we do you should check
out Audible.com!
They've got hours of audiobooks on space,
biology, history and more.
But if you like listening to people talk about
the world around them try :The Autobiography
of Mark Twain, Volume 1."
It was AMAZING.
He dictated the whole book back in 1904 so
it's like listening to him talk, literally.
Double meaning there… ha!
Anyway, you can find this and 100,000 other
audiobooks on Audible and download a free
book of your choice by going to AudiblePodcast.com/DNews!
Check it out, and please subscribe for more
DNews.
Y'all are great.
Thanks for watching.